bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de check-up votre magazine santé
et bien-être ce mois-ci nous parlerons
du téléthon nous avons pu pénétrer dans
les coulisses de son laboratoire de
recherche installé à Évry nous
évoquerons également le sida nous sommes
allés au local de l'association aide à
Versailles des tests de dépistage ils
sont proposés toutes les semaines nous
parlerons aussi du diabète une journée
de prévention a été organisée à Trappes
mais tout d'abord le premier sujet
l'autonomie des personnes âgées d'après
les chiffres du gouvernement les plus de
60 ans représentent aujourd'hui à peu
près 25% de la population
Rodolphe Dumoulin conseillé de la
ministre délégué chargé des personnes
âgées de l'autonomie s'est déplacer à
Montigny pour la troisième édition des
Rencontres sur ce thème il a annoncé les
grandes lignes d'un projet de loi qui
devrait entrer en vigueur en 2015
c'est un projet qui intégrera la réforme
de la dépendance celle qui avait été
tant de fois promise et reportée
c'est-à-dire la réforme de l'aide
personnalisée autonomie
mais aussi un volet prévention de la
perte d'autonomie qui cherchera à
identifier comment on peut mieux
anticiper les pertes d'autonomie car on
y peut quelque chose notamment par les
aides techniques par les actions de
prévention et puis un volet adaptation
de la société vieillissement
la perte d'autonomie ne concerne pas
seulement les personnes âgées elles
touchent aussi les handicapés nous nous
sommes rendus à l'Association des
Paralysés de France à Voisins le
bretonneux lors d'un atelier artistique
certains participants nous ont livré
leur ressenti par rapport justement à
cette question de la dépendance
chaque mardi à l'Association des
Paralysés de France rire et bavardage
rythme l'atelier cartonnage leur evarda
se connaissent depuis 30 ans elles sont
les bouts en train du groupe alors où
l'on parle de projet de loi et de
rencontres sur le thème de l'autonomie
Varda nous livre son expérience il y a
plein de choses encore qui ne sont pas
adaptées vous arrivez à un distributeur
vous savez s'il y a un rayon de soleil
vous êtes comme ça parce que vous
n'arrivez pas à taper votre code donc
bah ouais donc à chaque fois vous êtes
obligé quand même dépendre de quelqu'un
si vous voulez retirez de l'argent il
faut demander à quelqu'un d'autre mais
les distributeurs automatiques qui sont
pas adaptés on peut pas tout adapter à
l'handicap mais au moins faire un
minimum Varda a eu la poliomyélite à
l'âge de deux ans elle se déplace
aujourd'hui en béquille ou en fauteuil
et conduit une voiture adaptée Françoise
elle aussi est paralysée suite à ce
virus depuis l'âge de 14 ans lorsqu'elle
a arrêté son métier de technicienne de
laboratoire elle a senti le besoin
d'occuper ses journées et d'adhérer à
l'association quand on est en train de
faire des choses on n'est pas en train
de et de ressasser quoi que ce soit donc
puis ça permet de montrer qu'on est
capable de faire des choses comme tout
le monde
l'Association des Paralysés de France
compte 380 membres dans les Yvelines 10
ateliers sont proposés aux personnes en
situation de handicap mais aussi aux
valides cet atelier de cartonnage est
mis en place depuis deux mois pour
Christine la responsable s'est un
véritable plaisir ce sont des gens qui
se plaignent jamais et pourtant ils
auraient de quoi c'est
et puis c'est sympathique je veux dire
on a il y a une entraide il y a une
convivialité qu'on trouve pas partout de
quoi changer certains regards parfois
négatifs sur le handicap les handicapés
sont gays ils savent s'habiller ils
savent rire ils savent sortir et savent
s'amuser ils ont des amis ils ont une
vie tout à fait normal
vous le savez chaque année début
décembre c'est le moment du Téléthon
lors de cette 27ème édition plus de 78
millions d'euros de promesses de dons
ont été recueillies une très grande
partie sera reversée au Généthon le
laboratoire de recherche installé à Évry
il nous a ouvert ses portes le temps
d'une journée un reportage de Catherine
zulato et d'Élodie moine
un laboratoire de recherche financé à
90% par des dons de particuliers c'est
unique et c'est le Généthon créé en 1990
grâce au don du Téléthon pour lutter
contre les maladies rares ce sont
aujourd'hui 230 experts qui conçoivent
développent et produisent et thérapies
pour traiter les maladies génétiques
rares ces thérapies intéresse peu
l'industrie pharmaceutique et pourtant
cela sert à tous et madira c'est 3
millions de personnes en France alors
c'est évidemment chacune de ces maladies
touche un nombre limité de personnes
mais au global c'est 3 millions de
personnes touchées en France par les
maladies rares 30 millions de personnes
touchées par une maladie rare en Europe
donc un véritable problème de santé
publique et en même temps les
innovations thérapeutiques qui sont des
innovations thérapeutiques de pointes
qu'on fait ici dans le domaine de la
thérapie génique par exemple ces
innovations thérapeutiques de pointe
serviront également pour les maladies
fréquentes quand on travaille sur une
maladie rare du système nerveux et bien
évidemment ce qu'on développe là pourra
servir pour des maladies plus fréquentes
du système nerveux maladie
neurodégénérative maladie de Parkinson
mardi Alzheimer dans cette banque d'ADN
par exemple on collecte les prélèvements
de famille atteintes de maladies
génétiques on en extrait la matière
première pour la mettre à la disposition
de la recherche et grâce au don du
Téléthon tout est allé assez vite
Généthon a vraiment permis de développer
des outils thérapeutiques que l'on a
testé dans un premier temps chez des
souris pour le petit animal et
maintenant Généthon en est vraiment au
stade des essais chez l'homme et ça
c'est vraiment la grande grande première
aujourd'hui le fait d'être au stade des
essais chez l'homme de produire dans des
plus grandes quantités ces médicaments
expérimentaux c'est vraiment le but que
nous nous étions fixés même si le but
ultime ce sera vraiment la mission de
marché le plus largement pour pour les
patients mais c'est vraiment pour nous
un changement de dimension un changement
d'échelle et le résultat de de 25 années
d'espoir la mise à disposition des
médicaments pour les patients ce sera
pour 2017 pour se faire Généthon évolue
de laboratoire de recherche associatifs
à but non lucratif il vient d'obtenir le
statut d'établissement pharmaceutique ce
qui va permettre au laboratoire de
produire lui-même demain les médicaments
espérés c'est dire si le programme a
toujours besoin de plus de financement
et attendez donc beaucoup de cette
nouvelle édition du Téléthon
le 1er décembre c'était la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida depuis
2011 et jusqu'en 2015 cette journée a
pour objectif 0 nouvelle infection 0
discrimination 0 nouveau décès lié au
sida un objectif plus ambitieux quand on
sait qu'entre 30000 et 50000 personnes
sont porteuses du virus sans le savoir
reportage au local d'être à Versailles
une goutte de sang trois flacons le
résultat est instantané et fiable à
99,99% ce sont les tests minute un point
qui apparaît ça veut dire que ton test
il est négatif s'il était positif il y
aurait eu un deuxième point qui serait
apparu également voilà dans ce local
aide à Versailles il est dépistage ont
lieu tous les mardis soir le reste de la
semaine les bénévoles vont à la
rencontre des populations évaluées à
risque les hommes qui ont des rapports
sexuels avec d'autres hommes ou encore
les consommateurs de drogue par
injection un accompagnement
indispensable pour une bonne prévention
l'accompagnement fait vraiment partie de
la lutte contre le
VIH puisque sans l'accompagnement c'est
aussi donc beaucoup de prévention auprès
de ces personnes là c'est aussi beaucoup
de luttes contre les les discriminations
que les personnes séropositives peuvent
vivre et on sait très bien aujourd'hui
que la lutte contre la discrimination
de toute façon à réduire les risques de
contamination qui sont prises par les
personnes dans cette antenne
départementale 1,5% des personnes qui
viennent se faire dépister sont
positives elles ont fait la démarche
mais en France on estime toujours
qu'entre 30000 et 50 000 personnes sont
atteintes sans le savoir c'est une
maladie qui se banalise cette
banalisation là parfois c'est c'est
aussi parce que on pense
dans la population générale parfois on
se dit si jamais je
suis contaminé par le VIH ce n'est pas
grave je prendrai les traitements ça ne
changera pas grand chose sauf qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se met en place
il y a toutes voler social qui se
modifient en matière de traitement
depuis 1998 il n'y a que la trithérapie
pour contrôler le virus mais toujours
pas de vaccin
il s'agit d'une autre journée mondiale
celle du diabète une maladie qui
concerne aujourd'hui plus de 350
millions de personnes dans le monde
attrapent à l'Institut de promotion de
la santé une journée de prévention et de
dépistage était organisée reportage donc
là le taux de sucre dans le sang est
trop élevé
donc il faut rééquilibrer votre régime
ou votre traitement pour le diabète ok
feliper a appris qu'il était diabétique
qu'il y a quatre ans ce matin le
contrôle de glycémie le prouve sont
au-dessus dans le sang et trop élevé par
rapport à la normale il profite de cette
journée mondiale de dépistage et de
prévention du diabète pour mieux
comprendre sa maladie
c'est d'avoir les formations
supplémentaires c'est des rencontres les
gens qui ont de même problème que moi et
parfois on parle ensemble et puis
parfois bon il y a beaucoup de choses
parfois que j'arrive de mal à comprendre
par rapport à ça me fait comprendre quoi
ça m'aide on estime aujourd'hui environ
3500 000 diabétiques en France avec 400
nouveaux cas par jour c'est aussi une
maladie dite silencieuse résultat 700
000 personnes seraient diabétiques sans
le savoir souvent les premiers symptômes
une alarme pas des signes de fatigue des
vertiges ou encore quelques sueurs
froides
du travail on dit bon on travaille
beaucoup donc aujourd'hui je suis
fatigué c'est un coup de fatigue et puis
alors c'est pour ça que quand on faut
faire un bilan tous les ans voir avec
son médecin son médecin traitant de
façon tous les ans faire une analyse une
prise de sang ça coûte rien ou même
quand ils font un bilan complet en même
temps ils font une prise de sang pour la
glycémie et puis on voit si déjà ça
donne une indication le dépistage peut
en effet limiter les risques de
complications car pour certains le
diabète peut vite devenir une maladie
contraignante
je stresse beaucoup c'est une maladie de
diabète
qui atteint le stress
physiquement tout ça on est diminué et
c'est le matin c'est des fois c'est très
dur pour pour la journée quoi
les complications du diabète peuvent
être très sévères troubles de la vision
cécité accident cardiovasculaire voire
même l'amputation d'un membre selon
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé en
2030 cette maladie deviendrait
globalement la septième cause de
mortalité
ce numéro de check-up touche à sa fin
avant de nous quitter jetons un coup
d'oeil sur l'agenda et sur ce qu'il faut
retenir le 19 décembre le film donné
recevoir sera diffusée et suivi d'un
débat sur les greffes et les
prélèvements d'organes ce sera à 20h30
au centre hospitalier de Versailles
attrape le 7 janvier le docteur Jacques
Segal du Secours populaire abordera le
thème de l'angoisse du stress et de la
dépression lors d'un nouveau goûter
santé ce sera au centre socioculturel
des Merisiers des 14 heures check up
c'est terminé merci de votre attention
je vous donne rendez-vous dans un mois
d'ici là je vous souhaite de joyeuses
fêtes à tous et je vous dis à l'année
prochaine